you know a lot of people do feel like oh
comedians are
are depressed or they they're dark or
they're toxic or they're miserable or
um all of those things and it is true
for
plenty of them
but
the majority of people alive on this
planet
are toxic
or depressed
miserable
uh all of those things uh your family
members your next-door neighbors you're
the mail carrier
um and then you know people
talk about musicians or
or painters or poets that they're
they're all miserable and they're
suffering and it's like they are
expressing themselves publicly
so that's why they seem like they are
and it's also i think
frequently about um
the idea that rock stars
always die in plane crashes
it's like
no just a good one no yeah sure but also
a lot of dentists
die in plane crashes it's tragic it's
tragic but they're not public figures
so if we started clocking every dentist
that died in a plane crash we would be
like oh gosh i hope dad my dad's a
dentist he's about to go on a flight
this is i'm scared every time he flies
you know it's just when your public
figure
what you're doing
or how you're dying
or you know what i mean it's like i
totally get it like there was this 2014
study uh that was done that found that
comedians
don't live as long as less funny people
which first of all i think that's
hilarious i think it's funny that like
uh some some like researcher somewhere
was like i'm gonna divide
my test subjects into funny and not
funny and then figure out
who dies first so comedians that are
less
popular live a little bit longer